Frieden durch Waffen Frieden durch
Verhandlungen auch darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit dem stellvertretenden
Außenminister der Ukraine und dem
Botschafter ad in Deutschland andere
mainik schönen guten Morgen nach Kiew
guten Morgen Frau heale nach Berlin Herr
Melnik nach Marder Leopards und Co
wollen sie ja jetzt das Deutschland
mitmacht in einer Kampfjet Koalition
damit suggerieren sie als gäbe ist diese
Koalition schon wer ist denn bisher
dabei
wir hoffen dass die Deutschen hier
genauso wie bei dem Thema Leoparden auch
nach einer langen Zeugen eine führende
Rolle spielen werden denn eins ist klar
dieser Krieg ist nicht zu gewinnen nur
auf dem schlagwelt wir brauchen die
Luftwaffe wir brauchen die Marine und
Deutschland wäre in der Lage uns hier zu
helfen auch mit Eurofighter und Tornado
Kampfjets wir hoffen dass diese
Koalition schneller entsteht als das mit
dieser Panzer Gebote über 9 Monate
gedauert hatte denn die Lage wir haben
gerade gehört von der Frontlinie ist
sehr prekär wenn wir weiterhin abwarten
und schauen und erst später die
Entscheidung gefallen dann wäre das
vielleicht schon zu spät deswegen würden
wir wieder an den neuen
Verteidigungsministerin Pistorius
appellieren an die Bundesregierung und
dann Kanzler jetzt diese wichtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen weil wir an
die Ausbildung denken so ein bisschen
weil wir natürlich sehr sehr vieles
mitdenken sollten um diese Offensive zu
beginnen die wollen unsere Soldaten
nicht
opfern wir brauchen dafür modernes
Kriegsgerät und Deutschland ist halt in
der Lage die produzieren deutschen
produziert die weltweit besten
Kriegsschiffe U-Boote auch
Kampfflugzeuge die ja ausgemustert
werden vor allem die Tamaris also Sie
haben gerade die U-Boote und noch
einiges mehr angesprochen da gibt es ja
ein ganz klares NEIN nicht nur aus
Deutschland aber ich entnehme ihre
Antwort erstmal diese Koalition steht ja
noch nicht auch wenn die Amerikaner
angeblich bereits ausbilden am Kampfjet
sie haben in Sachen Kampfpanzer sehr
viel Druck auf Deutschland ausgeübt
jetzt sehen wir insbesondere die
europäischen Partner sind noch gar nicht
so weit es dauert alles noch verrennen
sie sich manchmal mit ihrem permanenten
Finger zeigt auf Deutschland
es ist leider so dass manchmal nur durch
diesen politischen Druck Entscheidungen
getroffen werden es tut mir leid dass
manchmal tun zu müssen aber es war halt
so und wir hoffen dass das in die
Zukunft nicht so sein sollte wir glauben
daran dass eine große Panzer Koalition
entsteht es werden aber noch Wochen
sogar Monate vergehen bis diese Panzer
auch die 14 Leopard 2 Panzer die
Deutschland versprochen hat an der Front
ankommen und ähm mein bitte ist dass man
dass man doch strategische äh und
planbare vorgehen sollte es ist klar und
da sagen auch deutsche Experten
Militärexperten die Ukraine braucht auch
die Kampfjets das heißt früher oder
später werden wir an diesem Punkt
ankommen und ich glaube es wäre an der
Zeit das das Deutschland das was man
verkündet hat nämlich diese führungs
Kontrolle zu spielen auch tatsächlich
das auch tun wird glauben Sie mir das
ist das was von vielen Partner in Europa
auch in der Welt erwartet wird und dann
der Krieg ist hier halt noch lange nicht
vorbei die Russen mobilisieren die
Russen schicken neues Gerät jeden Tag an
die Frontlinie und deswegen wir müssen
die Dimensionen dieses Krieges immer
noch immer wieder vor Augen führen man
hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck es geht
eigentlich mittlerweile nur noch um
Waffen um noch mehr Waffen und noch mehr
Waffen was ist denn mit
Friedensgesprächen findet da irgendwas
statt sind sie zu irgendeinem
kompromissbereit
also wir sehen leider bis heute gar
keine Bereitschaft auf der russischen
Seite über den Frieden zu reden und
deswegen ist es ja sinnlos man braucht
jetzt zwei für einen Tanz und man
braucht auch zwei für Friedensgespräche
im Moment ist es leider nicht so dass
die Russen bereit sind sie sagen zwar
immer wieder Verhandlungen aber
gleichzeitig bombardieren sie Städte und
und wollen Häuser wie Pro oder einigen
Tagen in Harke wurde die Uni ähm
zerbomben mit einer S300 Rakete das ist
quasi das Signal dass die Russen in der
Tat schicken aber wir wollen Friedens
ähm Gespräche also beginnen der
Präsident selenski hat ja äh diese
Friedens friedensformel Angeboten
bestehen aus zehn Punkten und wir hoffen
dass sie in zwei Wochen am 23 Februar
in der Generalversammlung der UNO eine
Resolution verabschiedet wird wo eben
all diese all diese Punkte besprochen
werden und das auch Deutschland hier
Führungsrolle zeigt viele andere Staaten
auf der ganzen Welt auch im globalen
Süden wo es noch leider viele Skepsis
bleibt in Bezug auf diesen Krieg wir
wollen wir wollen Frieden der Krieg wird
auf unserem Boden geführt das möchte ich
in Erinnerung rufen sterben unsere
Menschen Zivilisten Soldaten und glauben
Sie mir wenn Sie hier in Kiew Menschen
fragen würden also jeder wird sagen wir
wollen schon heute diesen Frieden aber
Puten scheint noch nicht so weit zu sein
und deswegen brauchen wir die die Waffen
um Brötchen dazu zu bewegen wenn sie
sieht es gibt keinen bewegen mehr an der
Front und aus einer militärischen Stärke
heraus wollen sie dann Russland an den
friedenstisch quasi zwingen so will ich
jetzt mal formulieren eine letzte kurze
Frage noch am Donnerstag kommt das
Europäische Parlament zu einer
Sondersitzung zusammen eingeladen ist
dann eben auch ihr Präsident also
wird er dann vor Ort sein um dann im
Anschluss mit den Staats- und
Regierungschefs zu sprechen wird er nach
Brüssel fahren
also diese Möglichkeit wird besprochen
aus Sicherheitsgründen kann ich das noch
nicht sagen aber sie haben gesehen
letzte Woche war die Kommission hier war
der Europäische Rat in Kiew zum ersten
Mal mit der Regierung das war ein
wichtiges Signal und wir wollen trotzdem
kriege auch in die Zukunft schauen wir
wollen auch die eu-mitgliedschaften
vorantreiben wir hoffen dass Sie
Verhandlungen über den Beitritt noch in
diesem Jahr beginnen könnten und dachte
das Thema der NATO auch das sollte auf
der Tagesordnung bleiben denn auch wenn
der Krieg morgen vorbei ist brauchen wir
garantieren dass ein neuer noch
schlimmere noch größere Krieg nicht
entsteht und um um denn zu verhindern
muss die Ukraine Teil eines Bündnisses
werden auch darüber sollten wir mit der
Bundesrepublik miteinander Amerikaner
mit einem Partner noch konkrete reden
das tun sie ja dann auch ich danke Ihnen
für das Interview das war der
stellvertretende Außenminister der
Ukraine und Gespräche wird es dann
sicherlich auch bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz geben die in zehn
Tagen beginnt danke Ihnen sehr
danke danke